[Music]
are you sure it's him
we called Gotham PD he hasn't been seen
for over a year what was that
disappeared they said they thought he
might be dead why come here why Detroit
the weather where's Batman
hey little birdies alone let's just hope
the helis passing through
I'm detective Dick Grayson you want to
talk about what happened can you help me
Rachel that's what she calls there's
something inside of me nothing Bad's
gonna happen you don't worry take care
of a kid is complicated you know that
better than anyone I know how healing it
must be doing what Bruce did for you and
you lost your parents what happened
between you and Bruce guess we had
different ideas of how to do the job
[Music]
we're gonna go see some old friends of
mine tada call me Cory what do you want
from me I've been looking for you there
are people out there trying to hurt you
total balance
I feel danger
there you are dear
what are you doing we almost make
sacrifices child
[Music]
doesn't ever go away what the feeling
you got left behind
[Music]
[Music]